[Musique]
c
marc déry commençons cette entrevue par
le moment dans sa vie je vous vous
remettre ce si ça vous rappelle des
souvenirs c'est le premier le premier
single en fait on avait gagné on avait
gagné audiogram comme péri à la pire des
futures stars gérer cdu
sûr que sarko
non sawan
à l'époque vous rêvez d'avoir une job
steady d'être un chanteur populaire
votre fc on peut réaliser leur voix
complètement complètement mutique est ce
que je voulais je me disais je n'en
demande pas plus je vais pouvoir avoir
l'opportunité de mettre mes chansons sur
un disque dans un magasin de disques
après ça je mérite juste pas grave vous
pouvez vous envoyer en sibérie m'en fous
fait que jeter commentait avec anaïs ça
c'était pour moi le stay bon enfin j'ai
réussi ma vie
depuis bull ont jusqu'à vos albums solo
vous avez raconté l'histoire d'un gars
qui dépensent beaucoup d'argent qui
voyage beaucoup et parfois qui se lève
tard oui ce que c'est vous sur le go
qu'il attendait pas tant je connais je
connais l'idée de se lever tard mais
c'est venu de sa venue de jardin
baragouinage il y avait un homme qui m'a
dit j'entends à stieg il est temps que
je fais ça pour ce jeu très peu je me
rappelle quelque part c'est ce que
motivant et n'ont en tout cas pas tout
de suite
finalement ça a été ça katowice
[Musique]
tard
mais ça fait quand même des fois il faut
que je t'aime mon but parce que c'est
pas évident des fois j'ai fait des
affaires en plus une barre des ac world
mais cinq salles en salles un opus à
quelque chose c'est bon je te vois
comment ça vient cette suite d'accord
lorsque vous proposer une chanson en
pratiquant comme ça parce que ça va
donner album vous parlais juste au max
ça reste à vous piquer sa soirée poker
oui j'ai jamais c'est c'est en jouant ce
mot je me suis gelé toujours d'un métier
puis joue vraiment des bains qui
arrivent des séries d'accords et
j'essaye toujours de faire des affaires
comme puis le le succès de chantier puis
après ça je l'enregistré même avec les
berges du web qui un mandat neigeux les
coûts d'une écoute l'histoire me
viendrait cela il ya eu plusieurs
histoires
d'ailleurs ses limites au que vous
montrez à jouer de la guitare rose est
complètement complètement et je vous
jure
à 9 ans quand j'ai vu un déguisement est
arrivé
[Musique]
à domicile
ça m'a complètement subjugué venant la
perte est comme paralysée punaise
cherchant chèque je voulais faire c'est
jouer comme suggestion 6 heures mais
quels belges apparel il veut tout le
long du faible qu il ya des filles qui
courent après puis à 20 des obstinés
pire il y avait de l'argent en direct
moi ça me plaît c'est pas la première
chanson des beatles dans la préfecture
le premier cas c'est ouais c'est ça a
pris la première liste a pas vraiment
des beatles mais c'est une autre qui a
joué avec les beats hausse est vraiment
l'amour de votre vie
oui c'est comme je connais tellement
j'étais tellement tous plus heureux au
pire que je sais comme maison que j'ai
connaît le thé avec leurs défauts leurs
qualités je le dis comme j'ai dit
dollars pose comme je connais comme je
sais que je peux je peux faire ça parce
que gégé connaîtront mais geyser vie
wab assesseurs à bien la lys
petit à peu près sur la chanson
j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé votre nouvel
album vous avez attendu huit ans à votre
entre votre quatrième et votre cinquième
album what this town album c'est pas la
musique et la musique j'en ai fait
pendant huit ans comme maire comme ça se
peut pas sa musique j'en fais tout le
temps des albums j'en sors pas souvent
parce que toute façon il y en a trop
dans le box a rien qui presse puis c'est
pas avec ça que je me mets riches en wi
fi xé pas parce que je sors un album que
là enfin je suis je vois je vois vérité
c'est juste c'est le témoignage d'une
période de ma vie puisque ça a été un
récit peuvent l'écouter c'est bien
correct
marc déry mais il faut merci pendant
trouvé ça très gentil c'est cool ça
parce qu'on peut se savait qu'une
chanson certains
je suis resté figé quelques secondes
avec offrons des perles de sueur
je les fait entrer pour qu'ils me
racontent me suis souvenue la fille de
chandler